[Music]
soil health you know isn't just one
thing it's like a system it's approach I
mean for us it's combining no-till crop
rotation cover crops and then planting
like native grass species and our
sensitive areas and our wetlands and our
salinity areas and along our watersheds
to try to make our land not only
profitable but sustainable for the
future it's a way to pull carbon out of
the air and put it in the ground and
[Music]
carbon them organic matter are basically
the same thing so if I can pull carbon
out of the air and put it in the ground
I'll make it to soil healthier we're not
seeing the salt issues as bad we're also
not seeing the mud when we go in to
plant if you take care of the soil it'll
take care of you how do we manage not
only the native Prairie soils but how do
we manage the crop ground to get our
soil structure back to where it should
be that's the real challenge that we
have I think the first step is to
understand and gain an understanding of
what we're dealing with in the native
Prairie soils building a resilient soil
if it's wet if it's dry if it's cold if
it's hot I want to soil that protects me
within those situations or is able to
handle those situations without costing
me a crop there's so many living things
there and when you go out there and dig
with the living cover it just looks
alive you're going to save money on fuel
you're gonna save money with the
fertilizer because that's staying where
you put it long run you're gaining yield
because you're increasing the value of
the land it also helped our workload
issues it allowed a better quality of
life for me and my family and as it
turns out it's a better quality of life
for the soil
it's better for the cows as well
diversity is always improves the
biological health and actually cattle
prefer diversity rather than
monocultures we've made a real push to
involve our landowners on the land that
we rent and leased to to get involved in
to understand what we're doing we have a
pretty good crop rotation that we're
happy with we're trying to have the soil
covered pretty much all the time
feeding the soils of pulling carbon
dioxide out of the air through
photosynthesis and feeding soil
microbiology increasing our soil organic
matter
it is accepting the responsibility to
continue to spread the word and to share
the things that you've learned over the
years share the knowledge the successes
the failures of what it's all about it's
about leaving it better than about it
long term my kids talked about farming
they they love being out here you know
and I that's up to each one of them if
they want to do this or not I hope one
or two of them decided to come back and
run the farm
[Music]
you